are you team noah or team marco well
your opinion might change when you hear
about how different these two characters
are in the books
do you even have netflix if you haven't
discovered the kissing booth
if you're anything like us you've
probably gobbled up everything that had
to do with the romance between elle and
noah
including the novels on paper their love
story is just as epic but there are some
pretty major differences between the two
that we can't
unsee like noah had an entirely
different personality
and l and lee they were actually
extremely popular so
buckle up because we're about to drop
some more major truth bombs and show you
just how the kissing booth movies would
look like if the filmmakers actually
followed the book
it's cool although ella noah are the
main couple in the films
ellen lee's friendship is just as
important in fact the main focus of the
first film is on
l breaking their sacred rules of
friendship especially the rule that
prohibits them from dating another
sibling
but things unfold a little differently
in the books author beth recalls
never actually included any friendship
rules in the novel
lee is only upset with elle because she
kept her relationship with noah a secret
for so long
we couldn't believe it either so this is
what you've been keeping from me
speaking of ellen lee they're basically
completely different people in the books
the films played off like the two teams
really only have one another as best
friends but in the novels
they have a whole group of other people
they hang out with remember warren the
boy in the movie who tries to take
advantage of elle
well in the books he never does anything
like that and is actually a really close
friend of ellen lee
you're holding it completely wrong
not only is elle more popular in the
novels but a lot of the hobbies that
make her the adorable awkward teen she
is
don't exist in the books for example in
the movie she's on the soccer team and
is the co-president alongside lee
of their high school's dance club but
the books include none of those
extracurriculars and she mostly spends
her time out with her friends
we still got it i love smell of victory
we can also add noah to the list of
characters that are completely different
from the books themselves
in the films we meet noah as the bad boy
popular kid who rides a motorcycle
while in the book he still is all of
those things he's a little more intense
than the movies made him out to be
in the novel he gets pretty violent and
controlling when it comes to l
and anyone who gets in the way of their
relationship it was actually kind of
problematic
he's getting the carl get the car out
one of the most romantic parts of the
kissing booth movie has to be when noah
takes l to his favorite spot underneath
the hollywood sign
they vent about their feelings and then
have their first time together
talk about movie magic and that's
exactly what it is because that scene
does not exist in the book
instead noah takes elle back to his
house for their first time
after rescuing her from a boy at a party
she was at wait this isn't the way home
i want to show you something what came
after ellen noah's hookup
lee finding out of course and that does
happen both in the movie and the book
just in pretty different ways in the
movie lee walks in on them kissing in
his room
and in the novel finds them making out
in an even more scandalous place
a classroom this one really didn't
change the plot much but it definitely
made for two pretty different scenes
would you wanna wait for me downstairs
yeah thank you
okay before the whole fiasco happens
with noah in the film elle plans a date
with a boy named tuppen but she ends up
getting stood up and spends the night
with lee instead
tuppen ends up crashing their hangout
and telling elle that he stood her up
because noah threatened all the boys
about ever dating her
in the book ella's actually super aware
of what noah is telling the boys but
still ends up going on a date with a boy
named cody who decided she was worth the
risk
despite landing a pretty perfect
boyfriend elle doesn't exactly have a
perfect life
in fact she's actually been through a
lot more tragedy than a lot of other
teenagers
but there's a huge difference in the
movie and the book when it comes to
elle's backstory
in the movie she's still struggling with
losing her mom to cancer
but in the novels she actually passed
away in a car accident
while it really doesn't make that big of
an impact on her story in the films her
mom's passing actually brings mrs flynn
noah and lee's mom and elf closer
together in the books we never really
ever see mrs flynn
just hear them out okay
while some of the changes made to the
storyline for the movie are probably
made to be able to squish
everything into 90 minutes we just can't
figure out why they made this next
change
if you've watched the kissing booth 2
you know that we get introduced to two
new characters
marco and chloe that get in the way of l
and noah's relationship
well in the books their characters exist
but their names are actually
levi and amanda strange
what is his name again marco marco
speaking of marco he and elle kind of
become a thing in the second movie
but they don't hit it off right away
instead they're actually pretty
competitive with one another and at one
point could definitely be considered
frenemies
in the books however there's almost
immediately a spark which definitely
made elle's long-distance relationship
with noah a whole lot more dramatic
we felt something i know it
going off on the whole marco and l love
story their ending in the film was also
totally different than what went down in
the written version
in the movie although elle admits she
still wants to be with noah
marco admits his feelings for her and
the two end off on a pretty awkward foot
in the books though they actually decide
to stay friends after cooling off their
romance
there probably wasn't anything more
heartbreaking than seeing noah's face
after he witnessed elle and marco kiss
this does happen in both the book and
the movie just in pretty different ways
in the film elle and marco kiss on stage
after their dance performance with noah
sitting in the audience
in the book elle leaves thanksgiving
dinner finds marco and the two kiss
without knowing noah is secretly
watching
the movie really said love triangle but
make it dramatic
can we just please talk about this later
please
we can't talk about marco without
discussing chloe the beautiful british
girl noah meets at harvard
movie l and bookel both get super
jealous when she finds out about chloe
but the way elf finds out there might be
something more than friendship between
them
is different in the movie than it is in
the book in the book ella sees a photo
of chloe kissing noah's cheek but in the
film
elle finds chloe's earring underneath
his bed when she visits him at harvard
elle is even more jealous when noah
brings chloe back home with him for
thanksgiving dinner but his
reasoning for her tagging along is
different depending on if you watch the
movie or read the book
in the movie we find out from chloe
herself do you know why he brought me
home for thanksgiving
he just wanted me there so that we could
become friends
in the book though he invites her to
dinner because she's from england and
has no one to spend the holiday with
elle's friendship with lee may not be
the biggest problem through the second
part but it's still pretty important
but their friendship drama is a little
different in the movie than it is in the
book
in netflix version lee's new girlfriend
rachel is jealous of lee and elle
spending so much time together
this makes elle question whether she
should actually go to college with leigh
in the book lee actually spends less
time with elle and starts to question
their dream college
did she speak to her don't worry
i took care of everything this leads us
to probably the most
impactful book to movie change there is
no third book
but netflix has already confirmed there
will be a kissing booth three
we may not know what's going to happen
to our favorite characters but we're
pretty sure it has to do with elle's
pretty big college decision
at the end of the second film she gets
accepted to both harvard and berkeley
so she's essentially going to have to
choose whether or not she wants to join
leah berkeley or noah at harvard
yikes
oh boy we can't help but feel happy
about some of these drastic changes they
made to the movies
while yes it's pretty different compared
to what the author really wanted
it wouldn't be the same movie we know
and love without them what was the most
shocking difference for you
tell us if you will be watching the
kissing booth 3 in the comments section
below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a thumbs up
to keep up to date with all things
ellen noah we'll see you in another
video
you